a lot of celebrities have their own fan
magazines that's when you know you've
really made it as we have your own fan
magazine and especially starts with
younger fans well I'm on TBS now and TBS
has a young audience and we have a young
audience so I thought I'd get on this
and well anyway now there's a brand new
fan magazine that features just me and
there's yeah or is it youngsters for
youngsters if you get youngsters cuz
they're the ones that love their cone Z
huh here's a promo if you love Conan
O'Brien yes that Conan O'Brien then
you'll love Conan beat the magazine
that's all Conan all the time in this
month's issue
Conan gets caught without makeup hottie
alert his all-natural look will make you
crush hard Plus what did conan finding
Kristen Stewart's trash we've got
exclusive details not even the police
report will tell you also Conan shares
personal vacation photos from his trip
to a Tijuana youth hostel his guest
Maria is one lucky runaway finally don't
miss this month's collectible poster
Conan chillax in on a Segway that's how
he rolls girlfriend it's all in this
month's Conan be available on some news
dance c'mon
why is my face without makeup burned an
area horrible lesions and burns right
right
what are they going overboard there why
it's not some movie about the plague